professor daymond johnson is president
of the academy of medical scientists
good morning uh
professor johnson um
looking at the position nationally i've
just been talking to
kevin fenton uh in london we're looking
at the position nationally how far do
you think we are into this omicron wave
well it's important to note that there's
been big variability across the country
we saw this wave arrive first in london
and if we look across the rest of the
country uh the rates of infection are
still increasing in all areas except
london you heard from kevin fenton that
there may be some slowing in london
we're not seeing that elsewhere so other
parts of the country are still not um
are still seeing rises and we don't know
how far that's going to continue that
said rates in london are still higher
than in the rest of the country
the um health centre says that uh we
don't need boosters um
or a second booster bigger pardon do you
agree with that
well i think there's very good news
coming from the ukhsa this week and also
from the joint the considerations of the
joint committee on vaccinations and what
they've shown now with new data is that
we look at people who've had the booster
who are over 65 and are now three months
from their booster what we're seeing is
that the boosters are holding up in
terms of greatly reducing the risk of
having to be admitted into hospital and
that's a really important result
even though we know that people three
months beyond the boost have less
protection from getting infected
nevertheless they retain the protection
from having been admitted to hospitals
so that's a very important result but
obviously this will be kept under review
as we get more data moving forward
an important
issue here is how people behave and how
they respond to the information that's
put out there now i've just been talking
to
as you heard kevin fenton and he was
saying young people who feel that
they've
had the had covered think that to some
extent they're immune they don't need to
be bothered with the vaccination and so
on um
what more broadly people
are now believing and there's some
evidence that omicron is less severe
than delta
are you worried at all that what's now
going to happen is that people might be
less cautious because they think to some
extent we're coming out of the woods
well i think it's very important that we
recognize that people have substantially
changed their behaviour during this wave
and since plan b
so the data show increased use of face
coverings in in crowded places people
are clearly using uh tests when they're
going to mix particularly with people
more vulnerable themselves than
themselves so people are assessing the
risk moving forward though we need to
recognize that we are now building up
immunity in the population both through
vaccination and through natural
infection what will be important in the
future is what other um whether their
other variants emerge that are either
have caused more or less illness so
we're going to have to keep a close eye
on that but people have responded quite
substantially my concern now would be
going forward i mean
is we will see changes in behavior again
obviously as schools go back people
return to work so there'll be different
patterns of behavior and we'll have to
watch very carefully how much infection
goes on being transmitted but we also
need to think about how we most
effectively um
respond in terms of for example being
able to keep people at work and so on
uh of course i i've been saying this
morning covert is the big story in town
but um
i think it's probably wise not to forget
that there is such a thing as
conventional flu are you worried about
the impact of
uh flu this winter
well just remind everybody that every
year we see flu being transmitted in the
population and very often the flu uh the
flu season if you like doesn't start
till the end of at the end of december
or going into january so um we there is
some there is but at the moment we have
very limited flu activity that doesn't
mean that we shouldn't see more what i
would emphasize is that we should
remember that the pressures on the nhs
are not just a
coveted omicron there are also other
respiratory viruses which we see in
winter like respiratory incisional virus
and other viruses so people are in with
other other conditions as well
and we need to watch carefully for flu
two things are important that we've
already done to mitigate against that
first is that we've had a very good
vaccination program for flu this year
higher uptake it's been done along with
the boosters and secondly the behaviors
that people are changing to reduce risk
of transmitting covid will also limit
the transmission of other viruses like
flu and other respiratory viruses
daymond thank you so much for uh such a
comprehensive briefing this morning
thank you